[Music]
okay we are live on the YouTube
everybody has it gone people man there
are so many things that I have to tell
you we're gonna do a lot here I've got
about an hour things have just ramped up
to sort of crazy levels 99% of it all
good there's just a lot of cool
announcements that I'm gonna make today
I want to tease a couple things that we
have upcoming my travel schedule has
completely bananas the next two months
are probably gonna be the craziest two
months of my lives my lives my life so I
have many lives of my life I just did a
really awesome interview through learn
Liberty that we're posting next week
that was just great I'm still vibrating
a little bit because it was just like
one of those ones where you just you're
kind of just right there with the guests
the entire time and we talked about all
the all the stuff that that I'm
constantly talking about on here
alright cool so we've got about an hour
here's what we're do we're gonna do some
Q&A so if you are on patreon you guys
get first dibs but we will take
questions if you want to throw some
questions in the facebook comment
section but if you're first dibs on
patreon which we already have some
loaded up I have a fancy iPad right here
and then we will also take questions via
YouTube super chat so I think you guys
know how to use that already throw in a
couple bucks it boosts your comment up
because obviously the comments section
and a live YouTube chat can be quite
bizarre yeah so you can go ahead and do
that and then I want to give you a
couple updates on things first off more
than anything else what I want to tell
you about is I am finally making my I
would consider this really my official
return to stand-up comedy this Sunday
April 8th at the Irvine improv which is
outside of LA right here about an hour
away from LA I am I am headlining and
it's just me people just me I'm gonna do
probably about an hour maybe there'll be
a special guest maybe not we'll see
about that we'll do some some crowd
interaction play with you guys some Q&A
all that good stuff
but basically so I think some of you
guys know this so I did stand-up in a in
New York City for about 12 years and I
had I lived that life that I lived the
good parts of it the bad parts of it the
struggling Road comic the guys standing
out on Times Square corners for
literally six nights a week for
sometimes two hours a night handing out
tickets no matter what the weather was
middle of storms we were out there doing
it sometimes perform for four people I
had sort of ups and downs of success at
one time I think I was the youngest
comic ever passed at the Comedy Cellar
at least that's what I was told the
Comedy Cellar sort of the it Club in New
York City
and did it for about 12 years then I
kind of shifted away from it the last
like six years or so I've been in LA
about five years started going more down
the political route I was always kind of
doing political stuff we stand up anyway
but obviously what I'm doing now is not
sort of strict stand-up so I'm getting
back in I did a gig about a month and a
half to go at the Comedy Store here in
LA and it's funny like I don't need it
that much so it was really freeing and
good so I've just wrote up a ton of new
stuff gonna try to blend in some old
stuff and just kind of see what happens
and I'm psyched to do it so it is at the
Irvine improv on April 8th I'll probably
do about an hour or so and you will
truly see like someone working through
everything and I think it'll be really
cool if you dig what I do so we've got
the link right down below for tickets I
think there's some tickets still
available it's about a 400 C Club from
what I understand I haven't been there
yet actually but I had Bob Saget here a
couple weeks ago who told me it's one of
his one of his favorite clubs in the
country so I'm super psyched for that
and that's one thing that I wanted to
tell you okay couple other things so
here's a big one because you guys have
been asking me about this literally for
years and I know I say literally a lot
but I literally mean this for years you
guys have been asking me when is this
thomas sowell interview happening about
a year ago we were told it was gonna
happen and then we were having trouble
coordinating I believe that he is 87 I
mean either 86 or 87 years old so he's
not traveling a ton so we are going up
to Stanford next Tuesday a week from
yesterday people we are going up to
Stanford we are renting a studio at
Stanford University we're flying up the
whole team up there and we are doing an
hour hopefully an hour plus an interview
with Thomas all I know he's been making
the rounds a little bit he did I think a
phone interview with Ben Shapiro and one
or two
other people but we are doing a live
full-on unedited video interview I am
beyond beyond beyond beyond thrilled to
do this I think he's probably the most
requested guest that we've had on since
we've been doing this show I think the
basic foundational principles that he's
talking about about classical liberalism
and libertarianism in role of government
and role of the individual and all that
stuff that you guys know I love I think
he is basically the the Jedi master of
all of it and he's been talking about
this stuff for 40 some-odd if not longer
years so I'm thrilled to be doing that
and just quickly you know shows like
that so we're going up to Stanford so we
have to fly our whole team up there so
fly a bunch of people we're renting a
studio for a couple thousand bucks
there's obviously other expenses related
to travel and all that we can do that if
truly the only reason we can do that is
because of the support that you guys
give us on patreon so that is a big
shout-out thank you to those of you that
support us on patreon or whether it's on
paypal or however else you do it which
you can go to patreon.com/scishow burn
report if you want to support that but
we'll never make the money back through
YouTube Rev on what it'll cost the
thousands of bucks it'll cost to rent
the studio and all that so I just want
to thank you guys for that I'm super
psyched to do it I couldn't be happier
to spend a couple thousand bucks on
something like that that we're gonna do
all right let me jump into a couple a
couple questions here and then I'm gonna
give you some other some other cool
things that are happening all right
super chat no question just want you to
keep up the good work I shall my friend
patreon how can we get this crazy world
back to a place of talking real issues
and not defending ourselves against
hateful comments because we're talking
about facts and not emotion I mean this
is really kind of the issue of our time
right and this is where social media you
know it's like it's just a tool you can
either use it for good or you can use it
for evil look how did you guys find what
I do here well I'm able to reach you
because of YouTube I'm able to reach you
because of Twitter and Facebook and all
those things but at the same time the
the endless amount of fighting and hate
it just seems to be ramping up and
ramping up and ramping up and I have a
very dedicated group of anonymous trolls
that really do not like me they pop up
usually on YouTube and Twitter more than
Facebook because Facebook is a place
where generally
have to have a real picture and be a
real person but yes there are there
there seems to be this sort of subset of
humans right now who are not trolls in
the sort of good way of trolling there's
a way to control and make memes and mock
people and be funny and silly and
subversive that's actually kind of cool
and if you get it they can insult you
and it's like a compliment and I get
some of those sometimes I share those
those memes or videos when people are
kind of mocking me or whatever it's all
good there's this sort of other set
though of people most of them are
anonymous but not all of them who just
want to watch the world burn
to quote Alfred from The Dark Knight
when he was talking about the Joker to
Batman they just want to destroy
everything they just want to fight with
everybody they want to upset everybody
they want to trigger everybody and I
think that unfortunately because for
whatever reasons our brains seem to go
to be more affected by negativity than
positivity although I think we should
all be working on it I certainly am we
seem to be focusing on those people and
they're really ruining the conversation
and by the way I'm not really I'm not
even mocking or belittling people for
anonymity online I have actually no
problem with anonymity online and for
those of you that are actually trying to
engage with ideas that are you know
dangerous ideas or whatever you want
talk or even not even that dangerous but
just ideas that you're afraid if you say
something about healthcare you're gonna
get fired I mean that's the
ridiculousness of where we're at at the
point or if you say if you come out as a
conservative or something you're gonna
have trouble at work or whatever it is
so I'm not mocking anonymity in that
regard well I think what I would say is
that if you use anonymity as like this
bludgeon to relentlessly attack people
and to only add evil into the discourse
I think you're actually a big part of
the problem right now but I know you
don't care if you're watching this in
one of your those you're one of those
people you're probably doing it at this
right very second so I think we have to
figure out a way look my Twitter bio
says Twitter is not real life Twitter is
not real life social media is not real
life what's real is being with people
talking directly to people really
exchanging ideas and that
but we're living in a time where that
that social media stuff it's leaking
into reality and I did a TM about this
about a year ago I said you know that
real life is becoming social media that
it's it's becoming all the trolling and
the hate and the anger and it's breaking
up friends and marriages and all this
stuff and we've all had to deal with
this but I would say the best thing that
you can do is stand for what you believe
in that's it
like there there's no magic answer to
this other than any of you I suppose if
you're watching this and you dig what I
do what you probably like is that I'm
here and I'm expressing ideas with
people that I sit across from and I tell
you what I think and I share my thoughts
for better or for worse or whether
they're correct or wrong or debatable or
whatever you want to say but not enough
people are doing that these days and I
suppose when I started this show a
couple years ago if there had been many
more people doing that I probably
wouldn't have seen an avenue to go ahead
and do it like if there had been this
great national discourse about ideas and
we were really honestly dealing with
things and all the problems especially
that I was seeing at the time with the
left and all that if that had really
been happening well then I probably
wouldn't be doing this I don't know what
I would be doing but you know here we
are so say what you think I mean it will
and I say this all the time but if you
are afraid to say what you think right
now it will not magically get better
down the road so say what you think
you've got to fight for what you believe
in because don't leave it for other
people to fight for what you believe in
all right a couple other things that I
want to tell you before I get back into
the to the questions here which are
loading up pretty quick okay so April
8th Irvine improv link in the
description right down below we've got
Thomas Sol next Tuesday we're taping it
next Tuesday it'll be up a couple days
later in San Francisco and then as most
of you probably know at this point I am
going on tour with Jordan Peterson so
I'm opening with Jordan we've started we
did one in LA at the orpheum and we did
one last week at the Beacon Theatre
which is this gorgeous 3,000 seat
theater in New York City it was a
surprise that I was going to be there
and the PA guy came on he said you know
shut off your earphones no flash
photography and now the host of the
Reuben Porte and before he could even
say my name the crowd went bananas I
have never experienced any
like that before it was particularly
cool because my folks were in the
audience and I'm warming up the crowd
getting everybody going these people are
super excited the line was around square
block in New York City it was down
Broadway down 73rd down up as it were up
after dam and back up whatever that is
73rd and 74th over there
but a full square block over there it
was just the energy was amazing so I
will be opening up for Jordan I'm doing
11 of the first 12 events so if you're
going to any of those and you can check
I think on Ticketmaster or you can check
on his website what the dates on all of
those are I'm doing 11 of the first 12
including the UK I'm not doing Detroit
no offense Detroit I would love to do it
at the Fillmore theater I've been there
before it's a gorgeous theater but I've
got a conflict related to actually doing
this show so I can't do that and then
Jordan tacked on about an another 20
dates I'm gonna do as many of those as
possible we're trying to figure it out
with my schedule at the moment but I
hope to meet as many of you guys out
there as possible I've been meeting you
guys all over all these stops that I'm
doing everywhere and it's it's really
been it's really cool I mean it really
is cool like people are waking up I
think in in big numbers to the craziness
so it's very exciting so I will be with
Jordan Peters and it's just been awesome
I mean spending time with Jordan and
it's like man I will tell you I will say
this now and I'm sure it's the exact
same thing I will say at the end of the
tour this man is is there's no
here they got everything that this guy
says publicly is the same exact stuff
that we talked about privately I had
dinner with him right before the event
in New York City and we did two hours
there were agents there and and a bunch
of other people and his daughter and his
wife and few others I mean we did two
hours of cultural Marxism and
post-modernism and all that right at the
dinner table then I go to the event with
him in the car we get up to the green
rooms up there we're talking about it
the whole time he that needed five
minutes of alone time just to get his
thoughts sorted out and then just goes
so it's awesome so most of them are
gonna be me warming up the crowd at the
beginning then Jordan giving his lecture
and then me coming out and sort of
facilitating the Q&A with the audience
it sounds like some of them might
actually be sit-downs where we're both
there the whole time and all its kind of
Q&A I'm on the on the 12 rules for life
but we don't have a exact
plan on that yet but I'm just super
sighted excited there's great energy
around it and I think that this whole
crew of people that you know as it's
become to be known the intellectual dark
web whether it's the weinstein brothers
or Sam or Ben or Jordan or whoever else
it is a lot of us are trying to do more
public events and and live podcasts and
things like that I'm potentially working
on an Australia trip that sounds like
it's coming together so there's just a
lot of cool stuff on that front
so I hope to meet as many of you guys as
possible okay here we go
patreon can you please have somebody on
to discuss psychiatric drugs and their
connection with mass shootings also what
is your personal opinion on the matter
thanks ed I love your show Dave yeah so
I do want to do this so look hey we
obviously are gonna do more on guns this
is becoming the discussion of the day
and we have to touch on it more and I
want to touch on a more I want to learn
more about it truly about you know I
know a lot about the laws that we have
but I honestly I don't know a tremendous
amount about the differences from all
the guns and it's pretty clear that most
of the people online including some of
the pros on this don't know much of a
difference either when everyone's
talking about semi automatics and all
this different stuff so I absolutely
will do more on guns I agree with you
that we need to have the mental health
discussion on this we are not discussing
it enough if you go I think by the very
definition if you go to a school or a
church or a temple or a mosque or a mall
or wherever it is and you shoot and
murder and maim innocent people by
definition there is a psychological
condition there does having certain
weapons make it easier to kill and
injure a lot of people very quickly it
does but we have to have an honest
discussion in a holistic sense and
unfortunately we're just not doing that
at all I got into a little Twitter
kerfuffle yesterday with Michael Ian
Black who I've had on the show before
who's a progressive a lefty you know
when I had him on I I obviously didn't
agree with a lot of stuff he said but I
was happy to sit there and listen to his
ideas but he sent out you know what I
think was in effect basically a crazy
tweet yesterday blaming the NRA for what
happened at you
tube but before he even had any concept
of what had happened cuz it was right as
it was all unfolding and calling the NRA
a terrorist organization I mean this
this is what is destroying the discourse
in this country and we've got to all
kind of reel back and realize that the
whole point of living in a free society
is that you're supposed to disagree with
people and you're supposed to argue and
get to a place that you can just
maximize freedom for as many people as
possible if your starting position is
the NRA it's a terrorist organization or
ban all guns or on the other side that
everyone should have tanks we got a real
problem there right we got a big chasm
there we got to get this thing to be a
little bit more manageable so I
definitely want to have those
discussions and yes it seems that a
disproportionate amount of the shooters
do seem to be on these drugs right it
just it just does seem to be that way
obviously there's not going to be a lot
of discussion about that on mainstream
media because so much
go watch mainstream media for a while
and Counting how many of the commercials
are for these very drugs so we have to
have some discussion about that too so
yes I promise you that I will get in on
that okay there's no Jesus there's a lot
here okay you're defending my liberal
principles is now a conservative
position quote is one of my favorite
starters in political discussions now
thanks I think it's probably the most
quotable thing that I've said in the
last couple years that sort of resonates
with people if you are a liberal and you
want liberalism really means
live-and-let-live as you guys know
without getting into a whole classical
liberal thing briefly if you believe in
the individual and that you should live
your life as you see fit that's the
foundational principle of liberalism if
you believe that we should judge as
groups and we should be caught in an
identity politics and all of this other
stuff and this intersectional mess of an
oppression Olympics where victimhood is
virtue then that's left is amatsu
aggressive ism is these days so there's
nothing liberal about progressivism so
I've tried to uncouple the word you know
the word liberal is dirty it to anyone
on the right right and it's a
conservatives right anyone and I've
really tried to uncouple those things
and show them that that
rolls in the classical sense of where
liberalism started is not your enemy I
think I've actually made some headway
and the fact that I hear about classical
liberalism all the time now and
sometimes I'm walking down the street
literally the other day I'm walking down
the street someone yelled at me
classical liberalism put up his hand
high-five and we just kept walking I
mean something's happening and we I
think we've been a little bit of a part
of that and it's very cool
but yes defending my liberal principles
of freedom and free speech and tolerance
and it goes down the line is becoming a
conservative position which is why I'm
finding it easier to talk to
conservatives that I disagree with when
it comes to abortion or the death
penalty where sometimes even gay
marriage or a slew of other issues where
I'm finding talking to leftist in an in
an honest forget leftist progressives in
an honest manner is becoming more
difficult that being said I just sent
out a tweet I believe it was Monday
morning where I invite I listed out
about 15 progressives that I'd love to
have on the show obviously Bernie and
Elizabeth Warren but then some you know
lower level and comic people like
Chelsea Handler and Sarah Silverman and
Michael Moore and Gavin Newsom and Van
Jones and a whole bunch of other people
a van actually had agreed to do it
publicly on Twitter about a year ago and
then CNN there people said no but I'd be
happy to sit down with these people if
they'll have an honest discussion I
truly want to hear their ideas like I
would hear any other idea but but if
you're going to do it within attacking
people or attacking me or just
bad-mouthing everybody I just don't want
to play that game as the kids say I
don't want to be dragged and I'm just
not gonna I'm not gonna play in that
game of personal insults and all that
but I'm happy to talk to those people
truly let's see
super chat I want you to have my babies
but I need to know you wouldn't abort
them did your live stream discussion and
move your position on abortion at all
look as I said to Ben in the last time
we we talked about abortion you know I
find myself but grudgingly pro-choice I
don't think and I and I think by the way
that most people forget the hysterics
that sort of fetishize abortion I think
most people that are pro-choice are bruh
grudgingly pro-choice I think well I
think and I'd have to look at some
numbers on that but I suspect that most
people
are that people don't relish the idea of
abortion I think most people do
acknowledge that it is ending a life and
we can get into the debate about when
does life start is it right when the
sperm meets the egg and all of that but
I find myself budging ly pro-choice
because I because I believe in the
individual and I know this is where some
conservatives will say well wait a
minute don't you believe in the
individual that is in the womb you know
at this point then I'm willing to
continue this conversation I truly am I
would put the the life of the woman and
the decisions and the mental capacity of
the woman ahead of that my cutoff point
would be about 20 weeks they've done
many studies where that's basically
where the fetus starts feeling pain and
I know as I discuss we've been that's a
little bit arbitrary because to say that
the 20 weeks is the cutoff well you're
obviously acknowledging then that 18
weeks is a life and I am acknowledging
that but I don't think taking away the
choice that the government taking away
the choice is the right thing and this
is a place where conservatives who are
supposed to be for limited government
they want the government to tell you
what to do with your body now that what
they would say is well they're defending
life because the Constitution says we're
gonna protect life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness so there's an intro
there there's a little bit of wordplay
there and but there's an interesting
philosophical debate and I will gladly
have that conversation with anyone that
wants to have it but again I I would say
I know at least 2 women in the last 2 or
3 years that had abortions it was not a
a great choice it doesn't even matter
whether they were irresponsible or
whatever it was but I it's just a
painful one and that's why when you hear
all these people screaming about how
they they're so right and everyone else
is so wrong or Republicans hate women
and Democrats hate babies it's all just
it's all just stupidity and I would say
that the best thing that we could do
right now whether it comes to abortion
or guns or whatever else is going on
we've got to figure out a way to start
tuning out some of these crazy voices
they are just trying to tear us apart
and just remember and this is maybe more
important than anything else and I try
to practice this in my own life people
never act like this in reality you know
all day long you can be yelled at on
social media by random people and
anonymous people and whatever when
you're
looking down the street if someone just
started screaming at you telling you go
yourself you crazy person and they
were wearing a fox a pink fox mask is
half of twitter does or whatever it is
some anime character you'd be like I
don't think that person's right I'm not
going to engage them but for some reason
we engage everybody on social media I'm
really trying not to I'm trying to do my
basic weekends off thing which I think
is catching on a little bit because I
keep getting emails that you guys are
trying to do it to I think what I'm
gonna try to do going forward is really
not do any social media on the weekends
at all so Saturdays and Sundays I
believe Jesus took the weekends off
Twitter I'm gonna try not do it all
except if I'm at an event you know and
I'm either you know take him I'm doing
something with Jordan on a Saturday
night I want to take a cool picture or
if I'm performing at a comedy club or
promoting something but not being part
of the it's not good to wake up on a
Saturday morning and just see everyone
fighting about the same they were
fighting about on Friday which is the
same they're gonna fight about on
Monday so I'm gonna keep trying to do
that and I know that a bunch of you are
doing it too which is pretty cool okay
let's see let's see do you have an
opinion on the recent Sam Harris Ezra
Klein dispute would you consider having
Charles Mariana as a guest and also
being attacked as a racist look god you
know i this thing about sitting down
with people and that you automatically
endorse their views is so is so idiotic
and boring it's actually boring to me
you know my friend my mentor and he's
gonna be in here in a couple weeks Larry
King
I've sat down with him before and I on
camera and I've also discussed this with
him privately but in the in his heyday
and I know I've said this before but in
his heyday CNN 1985 right he would sit
down on any given night with you know
the cast of cheers on one night then
Farrakhan the next night then David Duke
the next night then a Mentalist the next
night and then you know a guy that's a
magician I mean just this crazy array of
people no one in their right mind
thought that Larry King or thinks that
Larry King who's still doing it by the
way is endorsing all of these ideas so
it's just a horrible way of viewing
things that if you sit down with someone
you automatically endorse their ideas I
just think it's a it's just so terrible
so in and of itself I don't have a
problem having Charles Mari on I don't
know that I can get much more out of him
than Sam got out of him in his podcast
but I would say this that you know when
when the endless me hate machine that
just wants to call everyone a racist and
a bigot and all of that and just this
nonsense with box and I don't even want
to comment on the specifics of all the
emails that they went back and forth
with all the way from what I understand
Sammy is gonna have Ezra on his show
what I would say is that at some point
everybody gets tired of the nonsense and
you and for those of us that put
ourselves out there and are willing to
have these discussions and stake out a
position and publicly say this is who we
are this is what we think at some point
the hate becomes you just don't want to
deal with it so it's like I do have to
measure that sometimes because sometimes
people reach out to me and I'm just like
you know on this given week I don't feel
like dealing with this whatever whatever
the topic may be like I just don't feel
like dealing with the hate but again a
lot of that is just online noise are not
reality and I know you guys also are
coming to me to have these discussions
with these people and I actually enjoy
having most of these discussions so I
have to figure out how to negotiate that
as best as possible okay
super chat thanks for all your hard work
Dave love the show what do you think of
the idea that social media is the left's
equivalent of firearms the idea that
social media is their equivalent I'm not
totally sure what you mean by that I
mean look the left I guess what you're
saying is okay so the right has guns to
protect protect its rights I think is
what you're saying the left has social
media meaning they control Twitter and
Facebook and YouTube and Google and
bah-bah-bah
I don't know that the analogy quite is
working out for me but I would say the
best thing we can do because I know a
ton of you are as you know frustrated
seemingly with these social media
companies as I can be at sometimes the
best thing that can happen is that we
have capitalism we have competition
somebody's gonna go oh you're not happy
with what YouTube's doing well guess
what we're gonna compete and we're gonna
make a better site you're not happy with
what Twitter is doing and by the way
these companies do pop up most of them
fail but that's what business is all
about but the more that the market
alternatives to these sites because you
express your displeasure or you don't
like what Facebook is doing with your
data or whatever it is the more
opportunity there will be for new sites
to spring up for more people to make
more money on these sites investors and
see an opportunity and all that stuff by
the way very quickly I should address
the the YouTube shooting yesterday so
I'm not gonna even bother mentioning the
girl's name I have not tweeted a picture
of her or any of that stuff if she if
part of this was her wanting Fame she
ain't gonna get it on my dime what I
would say is it sounds like a lot of
this had to do with her frustrations
with YouTube so allow me to be crystal
clear as someone that you know has been
very frustrated with YouTube at times I
think I've been probably the most
outspoken person on the platform about
the D monetization and right now I think
we're having some issues with our feed
you guys keep telling me our videos
aren't being delivered and people are
being unsubscribed and all that putting
all of that aside the answer is not
violence I know you know that already if
you're watching this but the answer is
not violence and I'm sure there were
other psychological things there we
don't even know anything else about her
at this point it is evil event but you
cannot go into a place and start killing
people because you're upset with how
they do business I can't I don't even I
mean the fact that I even have to say
that really tells you that we're in a
we're in a wacky spot okay hey Dave
Jonathan pooja verse Brent Weinstein on
religion would be awesome and your own
Brooke versus ben shapiro and a couple
swedish guests including angry foreigner
and the sun and dodgy brothers i had t
no uh no you referenced that right there
still love the show okay cool I will
look into Tino's brother Nima
I think the names come across before as
far as your own and Bret I know there's
been some discussions about it everybody
schedules are a little nutty and I also
we're trying to look into doing more of
these as live events we're also going to
be doing a bunch of Rubin reports live
we're trying to figure out some details
on that I'm working on my agent so and
like a whole bunch of things are
shifting and and moving but I think the
idea of getting some of these out of the
studio and in front of live audiences
and getting more interaction with you
guys I think will be pretty awesome so
I'm psyched to do that
and speaking of live events just a
reminder the link is down below if you
are in the LA area this Sunday April 8th
I am doing an hour of stand-up maybe
there'll be a surprise guest maybe not
maybe I'll do some Q&A play with you
guys who
knows what's gonna happen as I return to
stand-up comedy at the Irvine improv the
link is right down below
Oh also I'm just gonna ah you know no
matter we got something huge coming in
May but I'm not going to tease it out at
the moment but something huge that is a
live event that is massive people is
happening in May okay let's see I want
you to get Linda Sarsour and Tamika
Mallory quiz them on fara Ken Fez
feminism state woke hombre by the way I
wrote a review of your kasich interview
yeah I mean sorry Sewer blocked me I had
invited her on the show obviously now
you know I haven't tweeted at her and
God knows how long but you know I'm sure
she's not gonna do it now because I'd
called out her nonsense relentlessly but
yes the left and the women's March and
all of this intersectional craziness
they are gonna have to negotiate how do
we have actual racists in our group
because they view victimhood as virtue
and if and because of that you're going
to have people who hate people based on
the color of their skin and their
sexuality and all that and in this case
it's coming out against Jews but by the
way it's gonna come out against Asians
as we're seeing and it's gonna come
again against that it's gonna come
against them - it's going to come
against everyone this snake will eat
itself and twenty years from now if this
thing keeps growing and growing and
growing although it will be eating
itself the entire time one day the
leaders of this movement who are young
right now are gonna go wait a minute
Barack Obama campaigned his first
campaign back in 2008 against gay
marriage he was a homophobe he was a
homophobe the way that people will talk
about people in slavery from way back
when so this is a massive horrible idea
ideology that has to be destroyed we
don't have to kill the people we have to
break the ideology and how do you break
it you break it with better ideas and I
think you guys know what my ideas are
which of course are much more related to
the individual and freedom and we need
less laws not more laws and we can't
have utopia because as Eric Weinstein
says on the way to utopia usually take a
little detour you get dystopia yeah so
who so I don't know what they're gonna
do about those people but the irony is
they won't purge their worst members
because they know that those tactics
will eventually be used on them
you end up having just this sort of
circle of hostages where everybody's got
a gun aimed at somebody else and going
if you say anything out of the line that
I want you to say you're gonna be taken
out then the the the thing gets smaller
and then you look around and it keeps
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
until there's nobody left let's see can
you try to interview some Neo
reactionary or tradition traditional
it's persons especially those involved
in the dark enlightenment so I'm
actually not totally sure what you're
talking about there but if you follow up
I'll try to address that patreon I have
teenage children I'm wondering if they
should go to college with all the things
going on these days in the humanities
and education departments at colleges it
goes on a little bit more you know I get
asked this one a lot when I'm going on
college is I get this particularly I
would say look I got it I got a pretty
good education I wish I had spent a
little more time studying it a little
less time smoking weed at SUNY
Binghamton State University of New York
but it was a public school my dad said
to me when I was in high school he said
if you go to a public school in New York
there they're significantly cheaper and
you can get a good education if you go
to that will pay for it if you want to
go to a private school or out of state
you got to pay so I looked at what my
options were and SUNY Binghamton was
pretty solid academically and that was
the one that I went to and I was a
political science major so I must have
learned something
that being said yes there is there's a
lot of problems of course with the way
people are being taught with the fact
that it seems that the inmates are
running the asylum the conversation that
I had earlier this morning which is our
learn liberty show for next week really
addresses a lot of this so so hopefully
you'll watch it I don't even want to
tease anymore than that
but what I would also say is that you
know part of the college experience is
you got to jump from high school to the
real world and hopefully you're gonna
learn some stuff in college learn how to
critically think and all that but you
also have to learn how to be a person
interpersonal relationships dating sex
drugs whatever you're gonna do and I
think humans do need a little time for
that from around 18 to 22 or whatever
you want to say maybe it would be better
that at some point we start having
something called late college where you
get to like choose at some point from
like you know 28 to 50 you get to choose
a year where you're allowed to go back
to school and somehow your page or
something I don't know
I don't want the government to do that
by the way it could be done by private
entities because I think then people you
know sometimes when you're older and you
go man I should have paid more attention
then I really would love to learn about
this or that or the other thing
that being said Greg Gutfeld who's buddy
of mine who's been on the show and I go
on his show often you know he wrote a
good piece a couple months back about
how there's so much opportunity to learn
because of YouTube now because of the
Internet you can listen to discussions
from Jordan Peterson and so many of the
other people that I've had on the show
who will teach you you can learn maybe
more from them than you can in in
college courses so I don't know that
there's an answer that's like the right
answer I think it really is a kind of
case to case basis okay super chat love
what you're doing would be interested
seeing you with Dave Smith Owen Benjamin
Tom woods nor McDonald that Jonathan
Pujo okay so that's the second time he's
come up MacDonald I've asked a couple
times in person I think he told me he
was gonna do it and then then I don't
know what happened I've had Owen
Benjamin on he's welcome back Dave Smith
I think is a libertarian comedian I
don't know him that well but I can look
into that Tom woods also kind of falls
into that line yeah I'm happy to keep
having these conversations guess what
I'm not going anywhere we're ramping
this stuff up so I will look into it
more let's see would you be willing to
have Sam hide on your show to discuss
censorship in comedy his show is
cancelled on Adult Swim because other
creators are on the network didn't see
would didn't agree with his politics so
he was sort of I don't I don't know that
much about that but if I'm not mistaken
he was the guy that was creating that
thing on Adult Swim that was thought of
as all right or something yes that would
absolutely be a conversation I would be
willing to have a super chat I'm
starting to think the people like
Michael Ian Black are actually happy
when mass shootings happen because it
lets them push their agenda
am I wrong because I hope so look I
actually I only know Michael from the
the hour that I sat with him here in a
few minutes before and after I don't
think he's happy I don't think he's
happy I think unfortunately the agenda
has actually overridden people's ability
to critically think and if someone is
killed
you know the shooting was unfolding
yesterday and I looked on Twitter and I
was like oh here
we go here we go everybody's gonna use
this to spin which way
half the people want it to be a white
middle-aged conservative Trump fan half
the people want it to be a you know a
brown Muslim man and it's like man this
is not the way to do this this is not
the right way to do this and we all know
it and then for some reason social media
seems to always bring out the worst than
everybody so I tried not to add to the
nonsense I happened to retweet and
comment on his tweet because I thought
it was so egregious to immediately want
to politicize it immediately call the
the NRA a terrorist organization I mean
look the the shooter we need to find out
more about the shooter but the only way
you could blame the NRA for it would be
did she wish she a member of the NRA did
she do it in the name of the NRA and
then ironically when it comes to other
ideologies that do call for violence and
then people say that they're doing it in
the name of set ideologies people say no
it has nothing to do with those
ideologies so there's just an incredible
lack of clear thinking on this there's
lazy thinking on this and you have to
try to apply those principles across the
board but no I don't think he was happy
I don't think I think I truly think that
99% of people on earth are good
basically good I think they're misguided
and confused and that's why by the way
the left is purging so many decent
people
Lindsey Shepard why on the show a couple
months back from wilfrid laurier in
Canada she did a video last week on
YouTube why I can no longer call myself
a leftist why is Brett Weinstein I don't
know what if he actually calls himself a
leftist anymore but I mean he's been
purged from the left his defenders are
basically libertarians and conservatives
and and those on the right why is there
so much more tolerance for ideas on the
right right now why is that consistently
why is there so much less smearing of
people from the ins I'm not talking
about the random Twitter person I'm
talking about from the intellectual
class the pundit class with the academic
class whatever you want to call that it
just is right now will that flip as the
pendulum swings probably but that's why
you got to try to have some principles
especially when they're hard to have
okay hey Dave what books if any of you
read that form your political ideology
oh this is from Facebook I mean I
there's a zillion books and many of them
are here from some of the authors I
would say if you want to read a
that really really helped wake me up
that I read must have been must around
97 or so there's a book billions and
billions by Carl Sagan it's actually his
last book he died before he finished it
his wife Ann Druyan who was also a
professor at Cornell finished the book
for him but he was sort of Inc I think
made perhaps and certainly by the end he
knew he wasn't gonna live much longer
and he was kind of giving a review on
everything he thought and I think the
best thing about Carl Sagan is that he
had a way of communicating massively
huge ideas in a very understandable way
he relates things back to the way were
tribal over sports and states and colors
and all this other stuff and it's just
it's just a wonderful book I haven't
read it in a while actually I think it's
I've got a different Carl Sagan book
right there ok let's see the dark
enlightenment which was referenced
earlier and neo reaction are the roots
of anti progressivism and make the
intellectual dark web look like
mainstream media google it all right I
gotta go guys I got to get on the Google
okay let's reminder I've got about 17
minutes to go here we're doing Q&A just
to catch you up going on tour Petersen
I'm at 11 of the first twelve stops
we've got Thomas Saul next week which
I'm super psyched for we've got a
massive guest at a live event in May
that I don't want to fully drop just yet
I'm going to the UK and with Peterson
and I'm also speaking at Oxford Union I
think on May 13th or so maybe it's May
14th but it's an honor of honors I can't
believe that they invited me so I'm
super excited to do that I've got an
event with Peterson in Seattle that
morning I'm flying to San Francisco then
San Francisco to the UK I'm doing some
TV thing there then Oxford Union then
Peterson then I fly back to San
Francisco to then do this event that I
just the super-secret event that I just
reference it's gonna be a bonkers a
couple months but I'm psyched guys
things are coming together okay let's
see here if I super chat I was gonna buy
heroin with this money so you better
answer would you talk to to jancuga I
mean he publicly said that he won't talk
to me I don't think there's I just don't
see any real point in it but I suppose
if he wanted to I would
yeah I mean I think he's one of these
people that's just not acting in an
honest way and if you're constantly
attacking people not ideas and again
unfortunately we see this much more how
often does someone come on my show and
attack a person really think about this
for a second we talk about ideas all the
time whether you agree with those ideas
or not I had Kelly Carlin in here a
couple weeks ago who's a good friend of
mine who's a lefty progressive okay that
week that same week I had David Frum
who's a never Trump conservative the
week two weeks before that I had Charlie
Kirk from Turning Point USA he's a big
Trump guy he just interviewed Trump I'm
willing to have all of these
conversations but try to think how often
were attacking people and not ideas it's
pretty rare there is a ton of that
coming out of the left these days and
that's that's pretty unfortunate anyway
I'm glad you're not gonna buy heroin
with that money who do we contact if we
want to get you to do an AMA on our
platform a moderator of a discord server
and I've had guests such as austin
peterson roaming millennial i love
Austin and roaming is just great too you
can go to Ruben report.com slash contact
by the way my my year has is basically
booked like the show to travel
everything but if you want me to speak
of your college sometimes we're
realizing that we have a couple off days
in between things that it doesn't make
sense necessarily for me to go all the
way back to LA if you want me to speak
at your college or your event or
conference or whatever it is
Ruben report comm slash contact I
forward it to my guys and we'll do as
many as we possibly can
guys I'm not seeing patreon questions on
here I'm just seeing super check if we
could just check on that please I think
you and ben shapiro should look make
your own video sharing site and call it
youtube I will talk to Ben about that
that seems like it has to exist already
do tube let's see are you worried at all
that this channels criticism of the left
increases polarization among the
audience reinforcing them on the right
I'm not really look have I been harder
on the left than on the right I'm pretty
sure I can honestly say that I have part
of the part of the reason that I'm
easier on the left is because I come
from the right I've also said several
times in the course of these 45 minutes
but there is more intellectual
flexibility on the right right now so I
find people you know I don't know
exactly what if we were
breakdown what my audience what it looks
like I think we've got either the bulk
of it is probably disaffected liberals
then we've got some Trump people but
we've got never Trump people we've got
science people and atheists and
believers and I get tons of email from
India and from Mexico and everywhere and
from Canada UK and just all over the
place so I don't even know exactly what
my audience is which actually gives me a
little freedom to just say what I think
but as far as look the the horrible
ideas of the right if you're talking
about like an like the white
nationalists or the KKK or eff people
who want an ethnos state or something
those ideas have no traction in
mainstream media they have no traction
on college campuses it's just a bunch of
crazy people who have nothing to do with
the foundational principles of this
country and and basically their ideas
are so the antithesis of what of what
this is what this incredible experiments
of America is that they can pretty much
be ignored the ideas of the left are
creeping into academia they're all over
media they are they are ripping through
society everywhere that's why to me this
has to be fought war does that mean
occasionally I've given more of a pass
to those people by default perhaps I
possibly if you think that's a criticism
me I can't tell you that's not legit I
am absolutely not perfect by any stretch
but what I would say more than anything
else is I think what I've tried to build
here is a home for people to honestly
come in and go this is what I think let
these ideas stand and then and then let
them stand or let the ball right and
that's what I'm that's what I'm gonna
keep doing okay yeah guys still not
seeing patreon on here I got a I got a
blank on patreon so if we can get those
in here or if you want to give me
another iPad perhaps hey Dave love your
work many times I get a sense of
helplessness around all the problems of
the world especially issues relating to
the radical progressive types do you
feel the same way and how do you deal
with it if you do look I think
inherently I'm an optimist if I if I
wasn't an optimist I don't know how I
could do this I don't know how I could
talk about this stuff all the time I
don't know how I could sort of be in the
political landscape and all this and I
know it's exhausting to everybody and
you know we're running out of those
places I referenced Eric before but as
Eric Weinstein says of commune
sense-making and i think a lot of the
reasons that you guys come here is
because we're offering a little bit of a
little island of sanity in that I
definitely do get depressed about it as
much as I worry about it I am world
weary I truly am I mean you know when
you're like if you see somebody and
they're you know sitting at Starbucks
staring off into the abyss if that's me
I'm most likely thinking about the
things that I'm worried about about the
trajectory of the world and can we win
this fight and can we bring enough
people back to sensibleness and can we
fix this and is Western civilization
really starting to Teeter I'm worried
about all of those things I think the
best thing you can do for that you know
one of the things I've been trying to do
is so you know I mentioned the know cell
phone thing or no social media on the
weekends in the mornings I try I don't
bring my phone into my room anymore so I
don't get up and start scrolling around
on on Twitter or anything but the other
thing I do is I usually put on some
classical music and I make some coffee
and I try to just kind of sit there for
a minute I feed I go out and usually
feed my chickens and I take Emma out for
a little bit Emma's the dog and I try to
have a little bit of space in the
morning before the craziness because the
craziness is always there we're the
craziness is just a stream you know I
was watching a thor ragnarok which was
awesome by the way
if DC could only get any of their movies
to be right I just watched Justice
League man that thing freaking sucked
but I was watching thor ragnarok and you
know when he goes through that
interdimensional thing whatever they
call that that bounces him between his
world and earth I kind of think that
that's what the the Internet is like now
it's just this like booming thing
multicolored interdimensional crazy
thing I can't wait for the for the
haters to quote me on that one Rubin
believe in conspiracy there is but it's
just this thing that's moving all the
time and it's moving at light speed and
you can check in or check out and I
think that we all have to do a little
bit of checking out more so that we can
be a little more real with people that
we're talking to and be a little more
real with ourselves but I definitely
struggle with at a time sometimes it
feels over overwhelming and I do get
stressed out and I try to manage it the
best I can but I'm separately definitely
not perfect in that
still not seeing patreon guys oh wait a
minute a zillion patreon things just
popped up okay so I'm going to fats what
is the degree that you really want to do
in the near future and why I keep having
fun I really want to get Bill Maher in
here i bill had a huge influence on me
for many years as I always say he was
sort of the standard bearer of the left
at least in terms of media for years I
used to agree with him on everything I
think I now see the split between
liberalism and leftism more than he does
I think he has an unfortunate habit of
always calling Republicans and people on
the right racist which I just think is
easy or for cheap laughs but I totally
respect him I like him I really really
want to get him here and I hope it
happens I used to want to be on his show
all the time I've kind of given up at
this point I've met with enough of the
people there it's like you guys know who
I am if you want to do it cool and if
you don't then that's fine let's see
have you talked with Austin Peterson
lately he's making waves with pro-second
amendment push for machine guns so I saw
a couple tweets on that but I'm not
totally sure what he was doing on that
so without getting into that yeah we we
tweet in DM and I think he's a great guy
he's the right type of person that we
need in government if you really want to
change things and you want to get some
libertarian or classical liberal ideas
out there so anything I could do to help
him would be great he's welcome to come
back any time
let's see hey Dave we hear a lot of talk
about encouraging open debate do you
think it would be helpful if those in
the intellectual dark web could make
concrete offers to debate people with
opposing ideas looking forward to seeing
you and Jordan be Peterson in Nashville
this summer sure I think Sam's doing a
nice job of this look you know Sam
Jordan by the way even though I would
consider them on the same side and the
general sense of things
massive disagreements on the definition
of truth and a series of other things
Sam addressed this by the way the
differences between why it seems that
people on the Left row is attacking
motives and people on the right aren't
so when when Ben and Sam were in here
they both oh no Jordan
miss misrepresented Sam's view on truth
Sam sent him an email Jordan said I'm
sorry I look forward to hashing it out
that's the way it's supposed to be Ben
when they were at a live event in San
Francisco was railing on something that
Sam said that was a joke and I know it
was a joke because I was there
and Sam emailed Ben and Ben said I'm
sorry I won't do it again
so there's flexibility in in these
quarters regardless of what you believe
to have these debates but yes we should
be doing more of these debates and I
think we're gonna do as many of them as
we can live what died have you been
doing it how's it going what have you
learned from it so I'm doing something
called a slow carb diet which is sort of
a modified version of Tim Ferriss ah's
diet
my brother-in-law Brandon who's here is
the one that kind of came up with our
version I've lost about 12 pounds in a
little over two months and it would have
been more than that except I've been
traveling a lot and sometimes in
airports it's just hard to keep up but
I'm basically doing no well really
no sugar but no grains no potatoes no
processed food so it's a lot of protein
and veggies and and it's it's been going
good I'm gonna see if I can lose like
another six or so I don't I don't think
I really need to but it's a matter of
also just trying to get ahead of the
curve as I have a two months of
craziness let's see
have you seen Ricky Gervais is Hume a
special humanity on Netflix it's so anti
PC on purpose yet very funny good
balance of sticking it to the left but
making truly good jokes along the way
that's what it's all about I love Ricky
we've had a couple tweets I think maybe
he agreed to do the show I got to follow
up follow up with him on that hey Dave
have a debate over nuclear energy with
Brett Weinstein and Michael
Shellenberger that would be fun is Brett
against nuclear in a way that I don't
know let me let me look into that but I
like both those guys I think mike is got
the right idea if you want to find a
same Democrat people right I hate
leftism okay this is the same Democrat
who's anti identity politics who wants
to use technology in the right way he is
a good guy had him on the show a couple
weeks ago check out the interview all
right quickly back to super chat let's
see I did that when I did that on
YouTube but did that one update on
having clay Travis and Jason Whitlock
thoughts on CNN canceling the interview
with Kyle oh cashews for retweeting
Travis okay I'd love to have Kyle sorry
I'd love to have Jason and clay in here
they're welcome any time let me follow
up can one of you guys write that down
I'll follow up about them doing that the
Kyle thinks so Kyle is is one of the
students from Parkland he's the one that
seems to be in my opinion out there
really listening to politicians meeting
with people
pressing a willingness to hear ideas
he's gonna come in here at some point we
just got to work it out when he gets out
to LA but seems like he's trying to
although he's on the pro Second
Amendment side of this seems like he
opened to ideas and he's not personally
attacking everybody all the time
I actually look I feel bad for these
kids in a lot of ways they've went
through something that is absolutely
beyond horrific right and now they've
been thrust into the social media thing
and are being attacked by journalists
and media companies and all this and
it's like these kids need to grieve too
but they're get it they're getting
thrust in and I and I actually sent Kyle
a message that I said just don't get
burned out don't get burned out because
we need voices like his out there okay
jumping back to patreon are you going to
start a book club so I think what we're
gonna do there's two things that I
really want to do one of them's a book
club one is them one of them is another
type of club I think we may do them only
through patreon because we're trying to
figure out how to do more community
building there and we've got such a cool
thing going you know on Monday I did my
8:00 a.m. to 8:00 p.m. patreon hangout
so I'm doing one-on-one chats with
people we do small Google groups I
talked to people in Australia and China
and all over the place it's awesome so
we're gonna try to do more of those and
also you know it's like when we launched
sort of new ideas you know to get away
from some of this toxicity we have sort
of an of an area on patreon where we can
do that and people really are coming for
the right reasons and are really willing
to bait so if you'd like to join us it's
patreon.com slash rubin report any plans
to come to europe i will be in the UK
for four days I think it's May 12th to
16th I'm speaking at the Oxford Union as
I mentioned earlier which I can't
believe I'll be with Jordan Peterson
it's either the night before or night
after I may have one free day I got to
reach out to Douglas Mari see if he
wants to grab dinner but maybe I'll try
to do a hangout or something and then I
will definitely get back and I need to
do another Europe thing I haven't really
done it in about 20 years have you ever
tried formalized meditation practice or
use a meditation app how do you feel
about meditation in general so so
David's big on meditation he uses that
app called the app the meditation app
that's slipping my mind at the moment
it's something there sometimes I've done
some of Sam's guided meditations which
he has on on YouTube
what Oh head space is the app and they
also have it on planes now I should be
better at it I try it is it is hard when
you're doing this and you talk for a
living and all that to just get the
brain to kind of slow down alright we
got a couple minutes left guys just a
reminder one more time April 8th
Irvine improv I'd love to see you guys
there I'll take as many selfies as you
guys want and I'll be doing stand-up and
some crowd work and we'll do some QA and
it's gonna just sort of be an old part
of myself that I'm that I'm bringing
back to life I started comedy actually
in May of my first stand-up was right
after I graduated college it was the end
of May of two of 1998 I'm old and so
it'll be 20 years next month which is
crazy so I'm making my return 20 years
from from the beginning which is
actually kind of cool let's see um or
that one I did how about a podcast with
Harrison Shapiro yeah I think we're
working on it we'll see what happens ok
and to finish up we've got one more here
I'll pick one more on patreon you've had
a few repeat guests on your show who's
your favorite individual to fall down
the intellectual rabbit hole with have
any interviews made you nervous prior to
doing them so I don't think I've ever
had an interview that made me nervous
there were a couple interviews where I
felt that I had to ask very specific
questions to understand the guests focus
so for example when I had stefan
molyneux on who i got a ton of for
doing and i do not regret doing it he
does talk a lot about race and IQ that
says touchy as subject as there possibly
is just ask Sam Harris right now because
he had Charles Mari on and then gets all
these articles calling him a racist I
felt that what I wanted to know from
Stefan mostly was even putting the
science aside for a second what what is
it that fascinates you by this I think
we did a really nice job in the
interview and I and I would do it again
but yes I got a ton of hate for it none
of them really make me nervous you know
we had John Kasich the guy was you know
a candidate for president literally
walking through my house it was actually
hilarious so we finished the interview
we do our thing in here
loved every second of it he was
incredibly nice and friendly and then it
was pouring rain outside and I had
mentioned something about having
chickens and he's like oh I'd love to
see your chickens but it's pouring so I
walk it he walks through my house walks
into my bedroom that day we keep the
house pretty clean but that day it was
just such chaos because I've been
travelling the bedroom is a freaking
disaster so there I have John Kasich
standing my bed's a mess stuff
everywhere Jordan Peterson would not
have been happy with me on that day and
Kasich is standing there looking at my
chickens through the the bedroom a
bedroom window I'm like man what a weird
life this is what a what a strange thing
okay I got a wrap guys but I'm so
enthused in case you can't tell about
the momentum we have going here I feel
great about everything that's happening
a quick reminder we just shot a little
video on this make sure you're still
subscribed to the show people are
getting unsubscribed make sure you click
the bell to get all the notifications
also we're getting a ton of listens
often now more than YouTube views on our
audio podcast which is on stitcher and
Spotify and all that good stuff and
that's it so Sunday hope to see some of
you guys at the Irvine improv and then
I'll meet as many of you guys on the
tour with Jordan Peterson eleven of the
first twelve except for Detroit and then
I'm gonna pick all the rest of them
Thomas all next week the big interview
with the unnamed person in May and a lot
of good stuff coming up and a lot of
colleges that I'm going to and all that
good stuff so thank you guys as always
and I forgot to eat this morning didn't
interview just did all this all I'm
running on coffee and water so I'm gonna
have a little something to eat
so thank you guys and we'll talk soon
all right